l'accès au tribunal de paris bloqué ce
matin par les avocats alors que doit
s'ouvrir un procès très attendu celui de
françois fillon de son épouse et de
l'ancien suppléant de l'ex premier
ministre à l'assemblée nationale marc
joulaud ils sont jugés dans la sphère
des emplois présumés fictifs de pénélope
fillon
on retrouve notre reporter katia
technique et katia ce procès va t'il à
pouvoir se tenir cet après midi comme
prévu bien on ne sait pas nous est pas
encore puisque la demande de renvoi a
été formulé par les trois avocats et la
réponse interviendra à partir de 13h30
seulement en tout cas nous avons déjà vu
françois fillon sa femme pénélope fillon
ainsi que marc joulaud entrée dans le
tribunal et certains avocats ont déjà
fait des déclarations donc affaire à
suivre
concernant le cette décision prise le
pour le procès pourrait être renvoyée à
mercredi françois fillon et son ancien
suppléant marc joulaud vont être jugés
pour détournement de fonds publics
pénélope fillon pour recel et complicité
et les époux fillon seront également
jugés pour complicité et recel d'abus de
biens sociaux
en effet pénélope fillon a touché plus
d'un million d'euros d'argent public
entre 1998 et 2013 et ce en étant
l'assistante parlementaire tout d'abord
de son mari puis celle de marc joulaud
or c'est bien cet emploi certains
d'aucuns le considèrent fictifs alors on
se souvient qu'en janvier 2017 le canard
enchaîné avait fait cette révélation
suivie de beaucoup d'autres en françois
fillon n'avait pas abandonné la course
près à la présidence malgré une mise en
examen
le le verdict des urnes a été sévère
puisque il n'avait obtenu que 20 01 % de
devoir ce qui fait qu'ils avaient été
éliminés dès le premier tour ce n'était
jamais arrivé à la droite de ne pas être
présente au second tour durant la
cinquième république
alors aujourd'hui ce procès très attendu
vous pouvez voir derrière moi il y a
plus d'une centaine de journalistes une
foule très compacte pour suivre ce
procès qui sera peut-être ou pas décaler
à mercredi on vous le dira vite mais
c'est aussi un procès très attendu par
la droite car la sphère fillon avait
vraiment entaché sa réputation est donc
la droite espère tourner cette page
aussi de la sphère fillon si beaucoup
katia technique